Welcome back.
I thought I'd do a couple of
centripetal acceleration
problems. Some of the more
common ones that you
maybe see in school.
So let's say I have a, well it
could be a hot wheel, or it
could be a car, a real car.
And say it's on a track.
So we draw the track.
What's a good color
for a track.
I don't know, yellow.
It's a yellow track.
So this is going to
be a side view.
And we all remember this from
our Hot Wheels days.
And the track does a
loop-d-loop, like that.
And then I have a car, and
let's say it's going at a
constant velocity.
We're not going to worry about
the car's, or at least a
constant speed, right, cause
the direction of velocity
might change.
Just not the magnitude.
So this is the car.
And my question to you is, how
fast does it have to be going?
What's its speed have to be
for it to not fall when it
gets to this point in
the loop-d-loop?
So it's going to go like this.
This is going to be the
path of the car.
How fast does it need to go?
So let's just think about it.
Of course, I have to give a
little bit of information.
Let's say the radius of this
loop-d-loop, I don't know,
let's say it's 20 feet.
I'm making this up on the fly.
I hope the numbers
work out well.
So what we have to figure out
is essentially, what is the
centripetal acceleration going
to be on this car?
And if we know the centripetal
acceleration and we know the
radius, we can figure
out the velocity.
So let's just think about what
happens to the car as it goes
up the loop-d-loop.
At this point, let's say when
the car's right here-- so this
is the car-- what is making
the car's velocity change?
Cause at this point the car's
velocity is like this.
And then at this point, the
car's velocity is like this.
At this point, the car's
velocity is like this.
It's always going to be tangent
to the loop-d-loop.
Well, this point, down here,
is actually going to be the
normal force of the
loop-d-loop right?
As the car is kind of driving
into the slope, the slope is
putting upward pressure on the
car that's making it go in the
circular path.
But as we go beyond this
point, we see something
interesting happening.
There's going to be the normal
force of the loop-d-loop
itself, of the surface.
And then we're also going to
start having gravity pulling
down on the car.
And some portion of the gravity
will kind of pull to
the center.
And it's a little complicated
at this point.
But at this point-- let me draw
the car, let me draw the
upside down car-- what
are the forces?
Well, if we want the car to just
not fall, right, the only
force is going to be the force
of gravity, or the
acceleration of gravity.
If the car is going fast
enough to offset the
acceleration of gravity, it'll
stay on the loop-d-loop.
So let's figure out how fast it
has to be going to offset
the acceleration of gravity.
Well, we know from the previous
video, that the
centripetal acceleration is
equal to the magnitude-- I'm
going to put an absolute value
around that so you know it's
not V for velocity
vector, it's the
magnitude of the velocity.
I know I keep changing
conventions, but that's good
for you cause you'll see
different things-- divided by
the radius.
Velocity squared over radius.
Remember, this isn't
the vector.
This is just the magnitude.
And once again this is also
just the magnitude of the
acceleration vector.
So we know what the
acceleration
vector is at this point.
Well, we're just worried
about the magnitude.
We'll say it's 32 feet
per second squared.
That's the acceleration of
gravity on the surface of the
earth, at sea level.
30 feet per second squared.
And that equals the velocity
squared-- I'll get rid of the
absolute value sign, or the
magnitude sign-- divided by
the radius, divided by 20.
And so multiply both
sides by 20.
I get 640 is equal to
velocity squared.
And so 640 square
root is 25.3.
So the car has to be going
25.3 feet per second.
So now I'll ask you
a question.
What happens if it's going
at 20 feet per second?
Well, if it's going 20 feet per
second, some place around
here, let me draw the path of
the slower car going 20 feet
per second.
If the car's going 20 feet per
second, it'll probably make it
pretty far, and then some place
around here, it's just
going to start falling and
then it'll fall down.
That's a car going 20
feet per second.
I'll ask you another question.
What's going to happen if
the car goes faster?
Let's say what happens if the
velocity is-- and I'll do it
in a different color-- I don't
know, 50 feet per second?
So this is a super fast car.
So if this was just
a simple orbit
problem, what would happen?
We have this centripetal
acceleration from gravity, but
that alone isn't enough to
offset its velocity.
So if we have no other forces
other than gravity, the car
would kind of exit its orbit,
you could kind of say right?
It would actually go
out of its path.
It might do something
like this.
Whoops, its path might look
something like this.
I know I draw these very messy
things, but it might actually
fly out, right?
So what's keeping it
from flying out?
Well, the actual surface of
the loop-d-loop right?
So we have something very
interesting going on here.
Well, let's figure it out.
What is the centripetal
acceleration have to be?
Well, if the car's going 50 feet
per second, in order to
keep it going in a circle, the
acceleration has to be 50
squared over the radius,
which is 20.
50 times 50, so that's
25, two 0's over 20.
The 0's cancel.
So the acceleration is
going have to be
125 feet per second.
The inward acceleration, the
centripetal acceleration has
to be 125 feet per second.
So what's going on?
Gravity is only going
to provide 32 feet
per second of that.
So the rest of it is actually
going to be the normal force
of the surface of the
loop-d-loop or of the surface
of the road, cause the
car is going to push.
The car is going to want to
kind of exit its orbit.
It's going to do something
like that.
And what's keeping it from
doing that is the road.
The road is keeping
the car contained.
And so it's essentially putting
enough extra normal
force onto the car and so that
force will kind of be applied
to the tires to offset that.
And there you have it.
So think of it this way.
If you were tied to the
loop-d-loop on the inside,
right here.
If this is some kind of western
movie where the
heroine is about to die, and
there's a car coming that's
going to roll her over.
If that car is going at exactly
25.3 feet per second,
it'll probably just
kind of bump
over the heroine actually.
The heroine probably will cause
the car to fall and she
probably won't die.
But if that car's going at 50
feet per second, then there's
enough normal force so the road
is pushing on the car,
and of course is an equal and
opposite force, so the car is
pushing down.
And that amount of the
car pushing down
would squish the heroine.
So I don't know if that was
disturbing or useful or
confusing, but this is
just another way
to think about things.
Anyway, I'll see you
in the next video.